the Gatwick drone is not just the tail
of an airport brought to a standstill
but a tapestry of thousands of personal
stories of trying to get away or to get
home
the biggest concern is for our friend
Jennifer here jennifer is 75 years old
she's a diabetic she has a heart
condition in anemia and we only have
enough medication for a couple of days
most of us you know just want to get
home for Christmas and make it back so
you know finally after today we're on a
new flight but hopefully it can be fixed
and they'll have different procedures in
place for if it does happen again we
arrived at Gatwick yesterday morning
full of expectations for a good family
holiday after New York over Christmas
the drone incident ruined that we know
back home and we're quite a bit of money
out of pocket so will those affected be
entitled to compensation the Civil
Aviation Authority says this is an
extraordinary circumstance which means
airlines aren't obliged to pay
compensation to passengers but there are
our rules if your flights delayed for at
least two hours your airline has to give
you free meals refreshments and even
free hotel accommodation if your flights
delayed for more than five hours you can
choose between being rerouted or getting
a refund but for extra costs like missed
hotel bookings or activities it'll come
down to travel insurance not everybody's
got that and not every policy would
cover this sort of disruption clearly a
lot of people have been affected a lot
of people have been disrupted we are
seeing steady steady stream of claims
coming into travel insurers it's far too
early to say how much this is going to
gonna cost the insurance industry and
that probably won't be no:1 until the
obligations and the responsibilities of
the airlines have been fully met
and it's not just the passengers who are
being left out of pocket these delays
will cost the industry millions these
are flights which would normally be
earning the airline's
a phenomenal amount of money should be
their most profitable day of the year
and they're not getting that money
they're losing out because they're
having to pay out some costs who cope
with the disruption UK aviation is a 60
billion pound industry this is an
expensive and painful shock to the
system
Adam Parsons Sky News